we start at the White House where
they're in increasing bluster from
President Trump about a caravan of
around a thousand to 1500 immigrants
from Central America the group traveling
through Mexico toward the US border and
the president says it must be stopped
he's considering using the US military
he says along the southern border to do
it this occurs as new concerns grow
about US troop commitment in Syria and a
possible trade war with China chief
White House correspondent John Roberts
starts us off tonight
from the North Lawn on the politics news
John Gregg it evening to you President
Trump still insists that the best way to
secure our southern border is with a
massive wall but in the absence of a
wall President Trump today floated
another controversial idea okay thank
you very much President Trump today gave
no details or would say if US troops
would be involved the meeting with
Baltic leaders today he revealed he
wants the US military guarding the
southern border he was thinking with
general mattis we're going to be doing
things military with it until we can
have a wall in proper security we're
going to be guarding our border with the
military that's a big step we really
haven't done that before
officials say the White House counsel's
office has been looking into the legal
aspects of putting the military along
the border the National Guard has been
used several times to assist the Border
Patrol and in the early 90s and military
Joint Task Force was on the border for
counter narcotics and counterterrorism
while a plan has yet to be formulated
just the idea drew a sharp response from
former Mexican President Vicente Fox who
tweeted to militarize the southern
border is to provoke more hate and
distance even further our nation's
somebody has to talk some sense into him
he's elevating his hate toward Mexico
causing a greater conflict President
Trump claimed victory today in his
public pressure Twitter campaign to have
Mexico stopped the caravan
of Central American migrants traveling
to the US border the president had gone
so far as to threaten NAFTA with Mexico
didn't do something
I told Mexico very strongly you're gonna
have to do something about these
caravans and they have to do it
otherwise I'm not going to do the NAFTA
deal NAFTA has been fantastic from
Mexico bad for us the group that
organized the caravan way blow
sinfronteras people Without Borders
criticized the president for demonizing
an annual event they claimed as a
humanitarian mission migrants should not
be abandoned because of some tweets and
political hate it's very characteristic
of Donald Trump to govern via tweets
while President Trump is seeking an
expanded role for the military in
defending the border he is looking at
shrinking the US profile in Syria it's
time it's time we were very successful
against Isis we'll be successful against
anybody militarily but sometimes it's
time to come back home and we're
thinking about that very seriously ok
but even the president's own advisors
say the US needs to stay in Syria for
the foreseeable future we are in Syria
to fight Isis that is our mission and a
mission isn't over and we're going to
complete that mission experts warier
u.s. pullout could lead to a resurgence
of Isis and remove a counterweight to
Russian influence in Syria today
President Trump was asked about his
relationship with Vladimir Putin whether
he saw him as an enemy or friend I think
I could have a very good relationship
with Russia and with President Putin and
if I did that would be a great thing and
there's also a great possibility that
that won't happen who knows and the
president dismissed the notion he isn't
tough on Russia pointing to his recent
order to expel 60 Russian diplomats in
the u.s. so there are many things that
I've done and not only the 60 diplomats
Germany did for France did for we did 60
there's nobody been tougher on Russia on
whether the US troops should stay in
Syria President Trump today revealed
that in his March 20th meetings with the
Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
on President Trump told Salman if Saudi
Arabia wants US troops to stay in Syria
to stabilize the situation well maybe
they should pick up the tab Brett how
that would work is really the question
John thank you